[Musica]
tornare a salerno
mi ricorda quando ero bambino ero lì
chiudevo gli occhi sempre più stretti e
vedevo la luce del sole filtrare
attraverso le tapparelle si trasformava
in delle linee orizzontali si univa
passante dopo passante con le mattine mi
svegliavo con la sensazione di vivere
un'esperienza individuale straordinaria
avere dei superpoteri è stata la
costante dei miei primi sei anni di vita
come quando incespicante noncurante
camminavo all'indietro come mi
suggeriscono dalla regia ma con un
ramoscello sul bagnoasciuga solcandolo
un atto che ad ogni adulto in questa
sala può sembrare privo di senso di
progettualità
eppure a me in quel momento mi faceva
raggiungere dei risultati inaspettati
allo stesso modo a novembre però ai
piedi dell'himalaya sugli angeli a
praticare yoga con aura mia sorella mai
fatto in vita mia
lo vedevo sempre qualcosa di lontano
distante apparteneva a lei non a me
eppure quando lei mi ha detto che da lì
a poco sarebbe partita mi sono posto tre
domande quando vado in india quando mi
ricapita di fare yoga dalle 5 del
mattino alle 21 di sera per un mese
quando e quando mi ricapita
l'opportunità di farlo con mia sorella
a quel punto abbiamo pianificato tutto e
siamo partiti totalmente impreparato
dopo un paio di giorni di estrema fatica
comprendo in realtà
c'è un significato a tutto ciò perché lo
yoga è una dimensione aumentata di
quello che faccio ogni giorno yoga e
digitale sono entrambi fatti da feedback
continui sono spingono verso il
miglioramento continuo non hanno paura
delle limite correre all'indietro
non è un gesto di incoscienza ma di
sconfinata fiducia vuol dire che
l'ignoranza ci emoziona anziché
spaventarci vuol dire e gridare alla
vita lanciare sfide
io me lo accoglierò invece nel diventare
grandi
da quando bambino dimentichiamo la
grandezza
procediamo a passi sempre più misurati
riconoscibili riconducibili addirittura
prevedibili dagli altri passi sempre più
piccoli più piccoli più piccoli in
natura l'insieme di esseri viventi e non
viventi in un ci siamo autosufficienti
ha detto ecosistema
eppure c'è una cosa bellissima perché
tra un ecosistema e un altro c'è sempre
un ambiente di trasformazione
l'eco tono il luogo dove tutto si
trasforma come il crepuscolo il momento
in cui notte giorno si mescolano
l'eco tono è l'equilibrio nella
trasformazione laga la garantisce la
trasformazione l'assicura allora
portandole cotone nell'uomo
immaginiamo il concetto di persona la
trasformazione avviene in quello che io
guardo in quello che mi guarda il
crepuscolo si trasforma dentro di me io
mi trasformo dentro il crepuscolo sono
io in relazione cade l'illusione della
separazione la più grande illusione del
nostro tempo
l'uomo eco tono è nato per esplorare per
condividere per interiorizzare ma per la
trasformazione necessario un superpotere
la fiducia quella che si dà prima di
ricevere quella che si dà verso l'ignoto
quella che si restituisce con
gratitudine e su queste basi e con
fondazione ex machina ogni anno
rinnoviamo il tecno pià un hub un
contest dove muro della tecnologia
pongono dilemmi etici tecnologici agli
under 18 bambini dai 6 ai 18 anni che
immagino senza alcun limite senza
confini senza emulazioni immaginando
rispondono a questi dilemmi e poi in
premio incontrano 25 figure strategiche
nel panorama europeo see o di
multinazionali responsabili di ricerca e
sviluppo managing director di fondi di
investimento e così attraverso la
fiducia che vogliamo generare degli
amministratori dell'oggi ragazzi ragazze
che ridisegnano le relazioni tra gli
ecosistemi che sono i cotoni
l ridisegnano perché si connettono con
soglie di innovazione lontane da loro
che presidiano attraverso capelli
bianchi e non riescono capelli bianchi
ed energia
il tecnico è un esempio di eco tono è il
mio grazie verso tutte le persone che mi
danno fiducia e come in un ecosistema
che ha una naturale temporalità prima o
poi si trasforma anche io devo mettermi
in relazione diventando i cotoni
soltanto diventando i cotoni potrò
evolvermi adattarmi a quelle che sono
nuove condizioni
camminate l'indietro diventa eco tono
grazie
[Musica]